[MUSIC PLAYING]
SCOTT ELLIS: Thank you
for joining us here today.
We're here for DA302,
Protecting Sensitive Data
in Huge Data Sets.
My name is Scott Ellis.
I'm a product manager on our
cloud security and privacy
team.
And a few of us are going
to be presenting today.
But just before we
start, what we're
going to be talking about
today is sensitive data
and how to protect it.
What you see up here
is just some examples
of what that might look like.
We're just showing
someone typing
in some random sensitive data.
And what we're going
cover today is, again,
when you want to do
something with the state
and maybe you're
sharing it with teams,
maybe you're running analytics,
training an ML model,
how do you identify
sensitive data?
How do you redact and mask
it, kind of protect it
inside the data itself?
And then how do you measure
that risk of sensitive data
or identifiable data?
So to get started, I'm going
to welcome Felipe here,
and he's going to take
you through some of it.
Here you go.
FELIPE HOFFA: Thank you, Scott.
Hey, hi.
I'm Felipe Hoffa, Google
Cloud developer advocate,
super happy to be working with
the product manager for DLP.
My teammates will show
you the demo soon enough.
So let's talk a
little bit about how
do we find the balance
between that utility and risk.
And let's see in
some public data
sets how useful they can be.
So for example, if you want to
go from one place from A to B,
this is a screenshot that
I took the night before I
had to give a talk in Berlin.
And I could see that it
would take 20 minutes for me
to get from A to B. But turns
out that the next day at peak
time when I needed to get
there, instead of 20 minutes,
it took me 30
minutes to get there.
And it's super interesting.
I'm glad that we can get
these kind of predictions
with Google Maps.
But the question is, how can
we get similar predictions
by ourselves.
In some places, we have public
data sets, like in New York.
I made this chart by
plotting every taxi trip
that people have taken during
a year around New York.
That's like 170 million
taxi trips per year.
And each of these dots,
it's one pickup point.
So you can use this data--
you kind of start with
a quarter like this--
and you can look at the
average to get from any place
to any place at any time of
the day during any weekday.
And you can run your
own predictions.
And that's really useful.
Then I did the towns
like this, where
you can see hour by hour how the
city moves in a different way.
People are taking short
trips, long trips.
In the morning, everyone
is taking starts
at central station and they
spread out around the city.
And I'm really, really
happy that this city
has published this data.
Though you can use
this for public policy.
For example, you can
see here this chart
that at 5:00 PM in
the blue line there
is a big dip on the
number of taxi trips
that people are taking per hour.
And the question is, why do
we have that dip at 5:00 PM?
It's not because people
want to take less trips.
But this is because there
is a policy in New York
that no taxi driver
can be driving
more than 12 hours in a row.
So the city enforces that law.
And then all the
taxi drivers decided
to do their shift
change at 5:00 PM.
So everyone goes
back to their garages
and the city doesn't have taxis.
And you may want to compare
what's the behavior with Uber
or other for hire vehicles that
don't have that regulation.
Well, as you can
see, the red line,
they don't have that data.
And the question is, how do we
use this public data to find
better incentives so we don't
have a problem when people
can't find taxis at that time.
This is 2015.
If you go to 2016,
you can see that Uber
and the other for hire
vehicles caught up
to what the taxes are
doing at the same time.
In fact, at 5:00 PM,
you have this date.
But you don't have
a date for Uber.
And then in 2017, you can see
how they have surpassed it.
They do way more trips than
their regular yellow cabs.
And the taxi drivers still
have that gap at 5:00 PM.
And this is on the side of
how we can drive utility out
of public data.
On the other side,
on the other hand,
we start to see
this kind of news.
Like, oh, there is a privacy
risk on publishing these laws.
We can find out where people are
going, where celebrities went.
And the question
here is, how do we
find a balance between
not publishing this data--
that would be the best
way to preserve privacy--
and all the utility that we
can get as individuals or we
can get at the city level
from publishing this data.
To find this balance, to reduce
risk when publishing data,
Scott is going to tell us
some of these techniques.
SCOTT ELLIS: Thank you, Felipe.
Great.
And so Google has been
working with a lot
of different applications with
a lot of users for a long time.
And so because of that,
we have done a lot
on the security and privacy
side to understand our data
and to protect it
so that we can still
make it usable for valuable
services for our customers.
And so we're going to share
some of the tools and techniques
that we've released for you
to use, as well, to do this.
One of those tools is our
cloud data loss prevention
infrastructure, or what
we refer to as DLP.
And this covers
three main things
that it will do that we're
going to cover today.
It helps you discover and
classify sensitive data.
It helps you go in
and mask that data.
Let's say once you
find it, it helps
you redact it, reduce
it, mask it, tokenize it,
things like that.
And the third thing is
it helps you measure
statistical risk that's
still in the data
or potentially
still in the data,
so you can understand
what's there.
And we're going to
cover those today.
I'm just going to
give a quick overview.
And just to get
started, we think
a lot about security,
privacy, and compliance.
All this infrastructure has
gone through a lot of audits
to make sure that as
we're handling your data,
you can check some of these.
We actually have a security
page dedicated to compliance,
as well.
And you'll see our
product listed there,
as well as many others.
Let's get into what it does.
So the first main capability
that it helps us with
is discovery and classification
of sensitive data.
So this is things like
Personally Identifiable
Information, PII, different
types of identifiers.
And a lot of what we're
going to talk about today
is how data, when it's
tied to a human individual,
can be sensitive.
So you release some number.
It's not that sensitive.
You tie it to an individual's
phone number or email address,
all of a sudden, that
number is very sensitive
because I know who it's about.
So to get started,
when you think
of direct identifiers,
things like PII,
first thing is discover it.
Find it in your data.
Out of the box, we have
about 90 different types
that we support that you can
simply go in, turn on, and look
for, both in the US, global,
and several other countries
where we have unique
identifiers in that country.
Next is what do you
do and you find it?
So there's a lot of techniques.
We're going to cover
a few them here.
But you see in this animation
we're showing a structured data
table.
And there's four columns.
And I'll kind of
talk through what
we're doing in each
column just as an example.
So in that first column,
it's an identifier.
We don't want to expose
that raw identifier,
so we are using a format
preserving encryption method
to create what we call
a deterministic token.
So what's happening is we're
actually taking out the value
and replacing it with something
else that still retains
the referential integrity and
the statistical properties
of that data.
That's key because if you
want to join on that data,
you want to run analytics,
you want to do a group by,
an average, you still can
do it, but you're just
not revealing that raw PII.
In the second
column, we are taking
some somewhat
distinguishing data
and we're making it
less distinguishing,
a term referred to as
generalization or bucketing.
And the idea here,
again, is we're
going to take something like
a senior engineer or vice
president and we're just
going to bucket them
into a general bucket
called engineer.
In the third one, we're
doing just partial masking.
It's pretty straightforward.
In that fourth column, we're
combining our inspection
with our masking.
So we're actually hunting
through the unstructured data
in that column, finding the
element that's sensitive,
and then doing something there.
So in this case, we've
redacted a few things
or applied that
partial masking again.
And again, all this running
is sort of one operation.
So the next part when we
talked about risk analysis
or re-identification risk, I'm
going to cover it a little bit.
And then Felipe is going
to go in more depth.
But just to give a
high level, let's
say you removed all the
PII out of your data, all
the direct identifiers,
all the things
that you can think about maybe
that seem kind of obvious--
so someone's credit card
number, social security number,
you've masked it or you've
done something there.
But what about something
like job title?
We kind of hinted at
it in the last slide.
But even just looking at
these five rows of data,
you'll see that there's four
software engineers and one
CEO of Google.
So that metric that
I have next to it,
let's say it's a very
sensitive metric.
Maybe it's rating that they have
or a donation that they made
or some financial or
medical information.
If you were to release
this information,
anyone who sees this is
probably going to figure out
who the CEO of Google is.
It might be one person.
If you look historically, it
could be two or three people.
But the idea is it's
a single individual
or a small group of people are
going to map to that value.
And everyone kind
of knows who it is.
Whereas if I said
software engineer
and I did an average of
those four values, even,
you probably don't know
what I'm talking about
or who I'm talking about.
You're just getting
a nice, usable metric
which is the average for
that software engineer.
So when we talk about
re-identification risk
analysis, this helps us
identify and pull out some
of those high risk outliers.
And let's just give
a couple examples.
Again, this is kind
of what the bucketing
thing looked like that we did.
We went in and took something
more distinguishing and bucket
it to be less distinguishing.
That's one way we would
solve that job title.
We'd bucket maybe CEO
or VP or senior VP
or whatever these kind
of high risk outliers
are into just one
bucket called executive.
Another thing we do with
dates that's kind of unique
is an option called
date shifting.
So in some cases,
the actual date
of a transaction or
the date somebody
was admitted into a hospital
can be sensitive by itself.
But if you were to
redact it or blur it just
to something like the
month or the year,
you start to lose some
granularity there.
And it can be very hard to
analyze a sequence of events.
So in this just really simple
example, we've taken records
and we basically
generate a random shift
in the context of that person.
So in this case, it's a medical
record number that we're using.
The idea is that we're
not going to shift
all the dates for
that one patient
consistently but then pick
a new random number when
we get to the next patient.
So we're going to
lose some data there.
We're going to lose
when the dates were
the same between two patients.
But we're going to keep
that sequence of events
within a single patient.
So you can still do
things like duration, kind
of predictive based on dates.
But you're not going to
reveal that raw date.
We talked about some of
the built-in detection.
Here we also allow you to go
in and augment that detection.
This is just a very
simple example here.
We're showing a little bit
of the code of what a custom
detector might look like.
We talked about sort
of tokenization.
And I want to show kind
of what that looks like.
You're really using
cryptography to create
these deterministic tokens.
In this example,
we're just showing
the raw key that would be used.
And every time we have
that key sent into the API
or sent into one
of the processes,
you're going to get the same
output for the same input
value.
So in this case, as you
see the first two rows,
they generate a token
that is the same.
And similar if you use a
method that can be reversed,
you can reverse those
tokens, as well.
And so when we apply this to
that original animation that we
saw, what we see down below--
and we're just kind of applying
different techniques
based on different types--
is you can start to
protect this data even
in the case of
unstructured data where
you might want to go in
and take that information,
train something on
it, or even share it
so people can see what's
happening in a support case.
But by reading that
bottom one, you
can't obviously pull out
and identify the person
like you could in the top.
But you'll notice with
the credit card number
even in free text,
we've tokenized it
in a way-- added some
metadata that we can actually
reverse that if we needed to
if we had authority to the key.
And so these are some
of the techniques
that you can apply, especially
looking at a lot of the ones
you would do on these kind
of direct identifiers.
But how do you
know when to stop?
How do you know when
it's enough, especially
if you're going into
a case where you might
be sharing this with a
partner or exposing it
a little bit more broadly?
What else do we
need to worry about?
And for that, I'm going
to pass it back to Felipe
and he's going to go
in a little more depth.
FELIPE HOFFA: Thank you, Scott.
OK, so what do we do next?
We know now how to
take our private data,
how to take our identifiers.
We can match them.
We can do different
things with them.
We can bucketize it.
But the question is, how do
we measure that we did enough?
How do we decide this is
the place where we stop?
So to understand the
reidentification risk,
there are three basic concepts.
One is the identifiers,
things that we really
want to remove before
publishing data or sharing it--
a name, a credit
card, a government ID.
But we also have
quasi identifiers--
my age, where I live,
and things like that--
that maybe if we only keep
my age and my place of birth,
maybe I will be completely
anonymous in a data set.
Or maybe someone will see that
we have someone from Chile
that's a speaker at
Google, they will
be able to identify
me regardless of that.
Those are my quasi identifiers.
And we also have
sensitive data that
is what we want to protect.
My health condition,
salary, something
that I would not like to reveal
that might be revealed if we go
through the quasi-identifiers.
So there are different
measures of how
you measure how risky a data
set is for reidentification.
There is k-anonymity,
l-diversity, k-map, delta
presence.
I will go through
two of these now.
And the good thing
is that the DLP API
can measure all of these for--
give you a value
for all of these.
So let me show you
k-anonymity, which
is a property for
that asset that
indicates the relative
visibility of its records.
And you want to measure how
many individuals you have
in any given group of data.
k equals 1 would
mean that there's
only one person in each
group in certain groups,
and that would make them
pretty identifiable.
To show you an example
on a public data set,
I'm going to take
all of the births
in Mexico that Mexico
has published--
took all of them
between 2008 and 2013.
We have about 13 million babies
that were born in that time.
And Mexico publishes a lot of
data about the babies and about
the mothers, including things
like where the baby was born,
what was the gender
of the baby, what
was the education of
the mother, what's
the civil status of the mother.
And what can we do with this?
This is a query that
I'm running DB query
where I'm grouping them
by all of the babies
by these four variables.
And you can see some
groups, like the first one
there is that we have 405 groups
that map to only one person.
That would be k anonymity
equals 1 for that asset
because we can find
some individuals.
The bigger groups from
the big various places
don't have this risk.
But there are some groups that
are really, really narrow.
And then we need
to decide, do we
want to publish a data set
that has a k-anonymity of 1?
Do we want to broaden
these groups by--
or do we want to
remove all of them?
But at least we know that there
is a k-anonymity equals 1.
And then there are different
ways of measuring it.
I did this with a SQL query.
But we also bring
it in the DLP API
so you can use the API to
just run a call like this.
And instead of wondering how
to calculate these values,
you can just call the LP,
ask it to-- in this case,
we are asking it to
calculate the k-anonymity.
And we're giving it the
columns, the quasi identifiers,
that we want to use
to measure this value.
And then you get these
values straight from the API.
Now, k-anonymity is a
pretty standard value
that a lot of the
industry, research, science
uses before sharing data sets.
But it's not enough.
Usually they say,
oh, you can publish
that data set once you
have k-anonymity equals 5.
But I'll skip this
slide on how do we
fix this if we want to
improve k-anonymity.
You can use generalization,
so instead of publishing--
you could either remove
some of these rows,
or you could generalize,
so for example,
instead of saying the specific
age or birth date of someone,
you could have larger groups of
people between 20 or 30 years
or so.
But let me look at this
example where I have--
if I have a k-anonymity of 5 and
I have a group of five births
from post-graduate
divorcees in [NON-ENGLISH],,
this is something that I
could know very easily out
of someone.
I could know when
they were born.
I could ask them, hey,
where were you born?
Was your mother-- what was
the education of your mother?
What was her civil status?
And turns out, in this data
set I can find five women that
had babies around this time.
And we could say that they are
pretty safe from [INAUDIBLE]..
And even if I cannot
tell who each one is,
they all have
something in common.
In fact, this data set has
a lot of sensitive data
like the health status of
the mothers at the time.
And all of the five
mothers have hepatitis B.
And maybe they didn't
want me to know that.
But even though we have
k-anonymity 5 here,
we are still missing diversity.
We would like to have more
diversity of the status.
So if we have different values
for hepatitis B in this group,
we would not be able to tell
that all of them have it.
And we would not be able to
tell if an individual has it.
And then how do we
call this measure?
We call it l-diversity.
And again, you can
just call the DLP API,
ask it to make sure
the l-diversity.
And you have to give it not only
the quasi identifier columns,
you also have to
set up what columns
do you want to measure
for sensitive attributes
where you want to have more
diversity on the values.
And then the DLP API would
tell us, oh, l-diversity
for this data set is 1.
You may want to change
some of these rows.
You might want to delete them.
You might want to
generalize them, et cetera.
I'm not going to go through
all the measures here.
k-map and delta process
are also super interesting,
because they are
able to incorporate
more statistical data
into these measures.
But we published a
blog post recently.
And also our documentation
goes over these measures.
But to remember here,
the best practices
when dealing with
data privacy, first
you want to minimize exposure.
With the DLP API, you can
remove sensitive data.
You can remove identifiers
if you want to remove them.
But you might also want
to reserve some of them
to keep the value, but
do some tokenization.
Do date shifting, do
generalization, et cetera.
And to know when you are
done to determine as a group,
as a team, as an
organization where to stop,
you can measure the risk
of re-identification.
And you can reduce that
risk by taking these steps.
But now it's demo time.
So let me welcome to the
stage my friend Masud
and Patrick that will show us
how to run this at a big scale.
PATRICK LECUYER: Thank you.
Thank you, Felipe.
Hi, everyone.
My name's Patrick.
I'm with my colleague,
Masud [INAUDIBLE]
will be starting up his demo.
So he's praying to the demo
gods right now that everything
will still be working properly.
We're part of a team that's
called the Swarm customer
engineering team.
So what we do is that
we work with customers
who have specific technical
problems that they're
trying to solve with GCP
and try to find a way
to solve that problem.
What we will be talking
about today, what we'll
be showing you, is linked to--
sorry, can you put
back the slides?
We're not totally
ready for a demo yet.
I have one more slide.
Sorry about that.
So what we'll be talking
to you about today
is how we work with one large
financial institution in Canada
that had a problem linked
to what we just discussed.
So they had those big data sets.
They needed to
de-identify those data
sets before they ran
analytics in the cloud on it.
They actually had pretty
strong regulatory requirements
to de-identify that data.
But they had to
do this at scale.
And they had to do this as
the data was either batched
or streaming to the cloud.
So the solution that we've
built leverages another Google
product we've discussed that
hasn't been discussed yesterday
that's called Cloud Dataflow
to run that large data set
through DLP API and do those
different transformations
that we've discussed today.
So what we'll do now, we
will move to the demo.
We will show you how
we run those jobs.
And then we'll explain
how that demo worked
and show you the
result after that.
So we can move back
to the demo screen.
I'll let Masud explain to
you while he starts the job.
And we'll come back to
explain what that job does.
MASUD HASAN: All
right, hello, everyone.
My name is Masud Hasan.
I'm a customer
engineer at Google.
I'm based out of Toronto.
What I'd like to show you
guys today, probably next 10
to 15 minutes,
it's how easily it
could implement
lot of the concept
that Patrick and Scott and
Felipe just talked about
is in Dataflow and DLP APIs.
So let's get started.
So you can see that I'm actually
in my project right now.
So what I'll do is
let's click on Dataflow.
And if you haven't used Dataflow
before, as part of Dataflow,
there are some of the standard
templates that you could use.
So if a click on Create Job from
the template, and you could see
there's a list of
already inbuilt template
already available to use.
So what it does is it
separates your development
environment versus execution.
In this way, you could just
pass some runtime parameter
and just run a lot of
those complex ATL task.
So the one that I'm
going to use today
is this one here
that I'm asking.
And let me just start
my cloud shell as well.
So in high level, that
pipeline, what it does
is it's going to take a
lot of CSV files, which
I have stored in a GCS bucket.
It's going to read
from the GCS bucket.
It's going to call the DLP APIs.
It's going to bulk the request
and then store it in Big Query.
So I'll do a GSCTL here.
I'm just trying to find the
path where I stored the file.
And I know this is
where you have it.
OK, so let's just copy this.
So you can see one
of the parameters
is asking me to give the
pad for the GCS location.
And just here dot CSV.
Now, for the Big
Query side of things,
I already created a data set.
Let me just show you.
You can see there's
a data set called
PII data set underscore--
sorry, PII underscore data set.
But there's no tables in it yet.
So I'll go back to my data flow.
So for the DLP
project, I'm just going
to use the one that
I'm currently using.
So you also have to pass a
template, a DLP template, where
actually all the
configuration is.
So let me just see where I
could copy the template from.
OK, so there are a bunch
of optional parameters
there we could also use.
So for our use case, let's just
say we're going to use 3,000.
So this is the parameter
that's being used to call
DLP APIs in a batch format.
So rest of the
parameters, they'll
just use the default one.
But for machine time,
let's just use something--
a higher machine.
So I think I'm
missing a job name,
so let's just call
it a DLP demo.
DLP data flow demo.
So you can see just having some
of those runtime parameters.
I'm executing AETL
job that's going
to do a lot of
tokenization task for me.
So let's just run this job.
So you also require
a temporary location.
So when you're writing
it to Big Query,
it requires a temporary
location in a GCS bucket.
So now this job is starting up.
Let me just show
you-- so you could
see there four different files
that I have in CSV format.
And if I just do a quick count--
So what we're
about to do, around
1.6 million rows in a CSV--
four CSV files.
And we're going to tokenize four
or five different phases, which
I'm going to walk you
guys through in a bit.
But it's going to be in
Big Query table format.
So with that, I'll hand
it over to Patrick,
who is going to walk you
through the DLP template.
PATRICK LECUYER: Yes.
So let's go back to the
slides for a few minutes
while the job runs.
So what we're doing right now--
so the job that Masus started
will actually take
a data set in batch
and run it line by
line through DLP API
to do a different number
of transformations
that were described a bit
earlier today in presentation.
So basically, we're
starting with that data set.
These are CSV
files, but we would
be able to support
any type of format.
So we can-- this is
a very versatile,
can start from any
format to any other.
Some of those columns have
identifiable information
that needs to be de-identified.
The problem that
we're trying to solve,
then, is try to identify
what those columns are
and how we configure DLP
API to do the right work.
So we apply the right
transform on the right columns.
And DLP API has a very
useful feature called the DMP
templates for that.
And when we were working
with that financial services
customer, this was something
that was key to the solution
because the problem
we're trying--
this is all fine and good.
This is one demo.
We have one data set.
It's simple to
understand what we do.
But as you increase
the number of data set
and as you add the
stream data to the mix,
it becomes complex to know
what needs to be applied where.
DLP templates will allow you
to decouple your code that's
actually doing the tokenization,
let it stay generic,
and put all of those transform
configurations somewhere else.
So what does those
template look like?
Those templates are
standard JSON files,
so can be sent directly
as is to the API.
I know that putting
JSON on screen
is not the most sexy thing, but
bear with me for a few minutes.
We will walk through
what that actually means.
And part of the JSON
file will identify
which columns transforms
needs to be applied to.
We will have different
types of transforms,
so two main type of templates
and then different transform.
The first one here is what we
called an inspect template.
The goal here is to run on a
semi-structured data-- well,
unstructured data in that case.
Sorry.
So we have some data.
In the case of our
customer, those
were customer
service notes fields.
So this is a free form field.
People are typing data in there.
Customer service people
might by mistake put
some identifiable data in
there, put credit card numbers,
put addresses, names, SSNs.
We've seen all sorts of 60
hours in those free form fields.
What an inspect
template will do is
that it will run through
those free form fields
and look for certain type
of data that we identified.
In that case, we made a list.
So we are looking for credit
card number, email addresses.
There is a series of default
info types we can look for.
As Scott was saying earlier,
there is also some custom
detectors that you could put.
So that template will actually
go and look for that data.
So for the column that
was linked to this,
we will look for data that will
mix those info types, either
the basic one, the custom ones,
or the RegEx that we have here.
So that's the first step.
So if we have
columns that we don't
know if we need to
de-identify, that
allows us to look for the data.
But just looking for the
data is obviously not enough.
We need to apply that
de-identification to the data.
So we will do this using
de-identify template.
And the example
that we have year,
we will use different
types of transforms,
because we have different
types of problems.
In some case, you
might do bucketing.
You are worried about k
anonymity or some other aspect
of your data.
In some cases, you just
want to obfuscate the data
or redact it.
In some cases, you might
also need that data
to be re-identifiable.
We had some use cases
around fraud detection
where we want to run fraud
detection models on credit card
numbers that have
been anonymized.
We don't want to run on the
real credit card number.
If we find fraud, we
need to be able to get
that token back to the
actual credit card number.
We need to know which
customer add fraud.
Otherwise, the fraud
detection model is useless.
So depending on the type of
transform that we're using,
we'll be able to adapt to
those different use cases.
In this case, the first
example that we have
is an example where
we can actually
go back and
re-identify the data.
So we will be using--
again, we are linking
this to the column.
The template will say
which column in our csv
this applies to.
And you have the
field user ID here.
And then it will apply format
preserved encryption to it.
Again, no need to go through
all of the lines of the JSON.
Again, not all that
sexy on onstage.
But what is important
to understand here
is that we can put this
outside of our code base.
So this is something-- this
is a template name that's
registered with DLP API.
When Masud started
his job earlier,
knowing the source
data it was running in,
he just pointed
to that template.
That template has all
of the configurations.
You see the column name.
You see the type of transform.
You see the keys,
the crypto keys
that will be used in that
case to do the encryption.
So you can really decouple
that code-- it's very generic--
from the actual transform.
All of the transform will add
some more type of templates.
So in this case, we are running
format preserving encryption.
We might have another case here.
What are we doing?
Same thing again.
We are identifying the column.
We're going, we're
configuring this.
In this case, we're doing
bucketing on a number.
So we talked about
bucketing earlier.
So we have numbers
within the range
you want to replace
this with the number
at the end of the
range in that case.
Simple configuration,
we're seeing
what the minimum value is,
what the maximum value is,
and how we replace it.
So those templates are a very
useful configuration element,
because you do not need--
what our customer
was scared about
was having to write
custom pipelines
for all of those data sets.
And that makes onboarding a new
data set very, very complex.
You do not want to have
to go out and write
code every time someone wants
to send more data to analytics.
You want that process to
be as seamless as possible.
Using templates and using a
generic pipeline in Dataflow,
you can do this at scale.
You just need to have a team
that will decide which columns
need to be de-identified.
This is normally offloaded to
a privacy or security team.
Build those templates
for new data set
and your data set is onboarded.
So very useful to--
especially as the data set--
the number of data sets
starts to scale up and
the size of the data sets
starts to scale up.
So at this point, I'll
go back to the demo,
pass back to Masud.
We ran that transform
through 1.6 million lines
and we'll see the
result of that run.
MASUD HASAN: Let's just see.
It just completed, by the way.
It took, like, few minutes.
So first thing, if
you guys remember,
there are four different files.
So if you click on one
of those transform,
it could see that
four elements added
and four elements outputted.
So we know that four
file's been processed.
So if you click on this
process file contents--
sorry, the DLP tokenization
transform-- remember,
we actually used
3,000 batch size.
So for 1.6 million,
you could kind of
get this number, 536 batches.
Then if we click on the
process tokenization data,
you could see that
it's translated
to close to 1.6 million.
And we just transferred
1.2 gigabytes of data.
So the last transform
was actually
to write to BigQuery tables,
which is actually matches.
So let's go to the BigQuery.
So if you remember
in my first set,
I actually showed you
guys the empty data set.
So if I refresh
this, you should be
able to see the
tables being created.
So all four tables
being created.
And I'm just going to get
into my data set again.
So if you do at least--
you can see those four different
files being transferred.
If you do a quick schema check--
so if you just do a head one--
so these are kind of our
data schema, looks like.
We could see we
actually picked a use
case that has a lot of
direct and quasi identifiers
in the file.
So for example, you
have job title and age
as a quasi identifier.
And you also have a
direct identifier,
like SSN, a person's
name and credit card
numbers, et cetera, et cetera.
So if you look at
one of the schema,
make sure it actually matches.
OK.
Let's do a quick count.
OK, so that number
matches for all those--
sorry, the four or five
different tables that we have.
And we can confirm
that the number of rows
are all the same.
So let's get into a little
bit more in the data.
So what if you
actually have someone--
let's say 18 years old,
a CEO for a company.
That would be really easy
to identify that person.
So what we did is I have
equity here I could run.
And you could see the part
of DLP using packeting.
We could actually pretty much
transform all those records
to thousands of records.
So you could see that--
so first thing you notice,
the cardholder's name.
It's actually
completely tokenized.
So we are using a
crypto hash algorithm
to tokenize the person's name.
If we scroll right, see all
the job titles being executed.
And since I'm only
going to age 18
and I'm also using a bucket
between 18 and 29 to group
them together.
So let's just see
[INAUDIBLE] this guy here.
OK.
Let me do it here
first and then do this.
OK, so let's do a comparison
about this record.
So this is in the Cloud Shell.
You're seeing the actual record.
So apparently he--
sorry, so Carson--
the original name is
Carson [INAUDIBLE]..
And this person is
27 years old CEO.
So if you look at on
the cardholders name--
I'll make it a little
bit bigger here.
So this is all tokenized
with crypto hash.
If you look at the job title--
so CEO, since we're
using bucketing,
is being transferred
to executive.
Look at the SSN number,
which is a direct identifier.
So if you look SSN here, 209
number, it's being transferred.
27 years become 18.
If you look the card pin,
which is also changed,
so that's one of the
direct identifiers
that we're using, using
format preservation algorithm.
And if you look at
the card number here,
so it start with the
original card number.
So it's 3735.
But it's been changed to a
completely different number.
So just quickly,
before I end this demo,
I just wanted to mention
that for the Dataflow job,
it could--
it doesn't have to be
from JCS to Big Query.
It could very
easily modify them.
That code became what I ran
is actually open sourced.
So you could go to the
Google Cloud Platform GitHub
page and just search for DLP.
You should be able to see.
Another thing is it could
also run those Dataflow
job using j cloud comment.
It doesn't have to
be UI if you wanted
to schedule it with the Cloud
Composer or something else.
With that, I'll hand it over to
Scott for the closing remarks.
PATRICK LECUYER: Yep, I'll take
a few seconds before Scott.
So as Masud just said,
this is all open source.
The goal of those is to
give you the building blocks
to be able to add DLP as part
of your ingestion process.
So we showed a
UI-based demo today.
You can start this.
You can really use
this as building block,
create your ingestion pipeline,
or add it to your ingestion
pipeline that you already have.
So as you go, adding more of
those ingestion pipelines,
you can use this,
add de-identification
that really enables you to bring
more data into the analytics
product without having to
worry how you will add this,
or without doing
de-identification
after the fact.
So if you want information
on the open source repo,
where to find it, how
you can customize this,
just come and see us at
the end of the session.
So I'll pass back to Scott
to talk about the next steps
and close.
SCOTT ELLIS: Thank you, Patrick.
And we'll switch
over to the slides.
Great.
So we just want to talk about--
thank you all for coming
and talk about a couple
of next steps.
And then I think there were
two questions in the Dory
that we'll try to answer
quickly before we finish here.
But first, again, there's
a couple of links on there
to go and check out DLP and
some of the other things
you can do with it.
Also, there are two
other related sessions
that you might find interesting.
One is today right
after this session
that I'll be going to as well.
I'll be speaking
there, actually.
It's at the Park Central Hotel.
It's right after this.
And another one is
on Thursday, which
is a customer looking at kind of
comprehensive protection of PII
and GCP.
And that's, again,
this Thursday at 1:15.
And so again, thank
you all for coming.
There's two Dory questions
I'm going to answer.
And I'm going to paraphrase
them, so if I get them wrong,
then just come
find us afterwards.
But the first one
asked is can this
be used in kind of
multi cloud or hybrid
or on prem environments?
The answer is yes.
So when you look
at our API, there
are really two modes
you can run it in.
There's a streaming
content mode.
And in that mode,
the data can really
come from virtually anywhere.
It could be on a mobile device
and maybe you're streaming it
before you save it.
It could be on another cloud.
It could be on prem.
Now, it is going to be
using our cloud to process
and inspect or
de-identify the data.
But that mode does
not persist the data.
So the data does not
have to be in GCP.
It doesn't have to be stored
in Cloud Storage or BigQuery.
It's simply streamed in.
And the response you get
back in that API call
is either your findings if
you're doing inspection,
or it is your actual mast
or transformed payload.
And that is on text, tabular
data, as well as images.
We can mask the images, as well.
The second question
was around keys.
I know we showed
some examples here
where you actually saw the key.
So probably don't
use those keys.
But that was a
question around can you
use something like KMS or
a Key Management System
on those keys?
And the answer is yes.
So we actually have an
integration with KMS.
The idea is that you
would wrap the key in KMS.
So the thing you're
providing in the API call
or in a pipeline, like in
that template, is wrapped.
So if someone saw it,
somebody got access to it,
they can't actually run
the key to tokenize data
or de-tokenize data.
They would have to have
actual access to the key.
So that gives you another avenue
for auditing and access control
using KMS.
So that is definitely
the preferred method.
But if you have
other systems where
you need to stream the
key in, we do support it.
And I think that was the last
one on the Dory question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SCOTT ELLIS: OK.
SCOTT ELLIS: So the
performance implications
of DLP, so it depends
a lot, obviously,
on how you're using it.
We have built the streaming
API to support real time
environments.
So again, we have some demos
we can show you at our booth
if you want to stop by where
you're typing in one box
and it's literally
showing up pretty much
in real time in the other side.
So again, it
depends a little bit
on the complexity of
what you're sending in.
How big it is, how much it is.
But it is going to add a
little bit of processing
into that pipeline.
Now, if you're doing--
at rest scanning is another
thing that we do support.
So imagine you have your data
warehouse or your data lake,
something sitting in GCS and you
wanted to sample scans or just
periodic scans of that data.
We also support that mode.
That's our second
mode, which we kind of
refer to it as a storage mode.
And when you're
doing that, again,
depending on how big your data
is, how you're sampling it,
things like that,
but you're usually
running that in kind of a
background periodic job.
In the example, I think,
today with Dataflow,
we were using the
streaming part of the API
and using Dataflow to
parallelize everything.
And so we were able
to process a lot
of data in a very short window.
And so that's kind of
a lot of the power.
Because it's not
persisting data,
because it doesn't have state,
you can parallelize the API.
And at that point
you're just dealing
with number of workers, total
quota, and things like that.
But with that, I think we're
just about out of time.
Thank you again for coming.
If you have any questions,
come find us at the booth
over in the security
neighborhood.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]